yeah he went to welcome to video playing
bumper tab who is that
no name butter sir it's an order account
92 Wow
okay I don't mind you play something
classical against and remove like that
Wow now can play many things again such
a such a setup let's see a kiddo
I know how logical that is with 90 to f3
okay
I mean he's moved the night a million
time so I can probably afford to play in
gambit style like tempting to take half
194 then so I'm here 386 23
yeah that's comfortable for blanket but
so nothing special willing okay I'm just
going to complete development here
should be 7
yeah how to how to play here I can
prepare five here you can go a 95 but
it's nothing special I always have 97
getting into trade some stuff is really
doing nothing at all so let's see has
opened us up
yeah black is quite okay here it's
nothing special but it's very okay what
is he thinking about okay look some
quite well coordinated but white has
traded two sets of minor pieces and it's
extremely solid try to play quickly okay
yeah you want to fight for that d4
square something that I can of course
anticipate here with tonight potentially
coming now even even just c4 isn't all
the terrible
I just got cool Queen default so for
double attack that's a bit annoying hmm
net plans before efforts didn't get to
play it
yeah I played this in a bit of a sloppy
way didn't take it serious enough now
White has some has some pressure now
okay eight I'm going to play next trade
down
nyan it's probably just a pretty
substantial simplification but not happy
on this which ok cannot allow age 5 I
know that they are lots of porn on light
squares but still a BG 4 even
yeah that's not put to play f5 it seems
okay and stick this first so if I go if
I go get eight I mean then f5 got Queen
g3 I don't know i mean there are this
will come to play yeah
queen g3 threatening queenie one I
thought I don't think this can be all
that terrible for me okay so this is dot
this is hanging on b6 potentially
yeah - five is quite annoying
so you should tear three you wants to do
can also go here just stop this time
warning maybe it's going to fall now
I don't know I I don't quite understand
what white is doing here I think you I
know I think I'm okay yep yes to go
backwards now he tries to go with the
king there after him be quick with my
with my H pawn so you would sacrifice
now I guess and then I'm just about
ready here to stop this King ahead on
the clock probably hoping for stalemate
check check check
life for thin for soon okay yeah what's
better there but I think he somehow
bring he somehow and misjudged this
ending I don't know up to here I am okay
but I completely
I underestimated this okay seven
business yeah yeah that I was thinking
that it's not a big deal iam but it's
really really annoying so age five four
can I think white white is just a bit
better here and f5 is right yeah that is
the the milk that is the most principled
I would have gone here and they didn't
see how exactly wins but it looks really
really really off like here that's what
the engine is giving a character let's
do this and it gives plus one I mean I'm
not not sure if this is something really
completely a forcing or anything but it
looks pretty ugly yeah I think this is
what he should have done but King March
and doesn't need anything I think he I'm
fine
and he started to play for a loss
tomorrow yeah this is just wrong Bishop
isn't doing anything and I'm just
netting g2 yeah but this is breaking
through
and it's an easy winner Pizza yeah he
just doing here mr. opportunity's there
with a five and after that I think he
tried to play for win in a position
where that was not warranted anymore
okay guys thanks for watching